Boris Johnson the British Prime Minister
took his place in Parliament once more
following that event election victory
last week very convincing one
for Boris Johnson winning a strong
parliamentary majority and as a result
of that he was able to lay out his
legislative agenda going forward over
the next Parliament now one of those
issues which is arisen because of that
election is the question of Scottish
independence and the British government
saying that they're not going to even
entertain it as they of course want to
maintain the Union we should resist the
calls of those who would break up the
United Kingdom respectfully defended
that partnership and now all of this has
been brought into close to focus
following last week's general election
the SNP doing very well
winning 48 seats and pretty much a very
overwhelming majority almost all of the
seats in Scotland while the Tories won a
majority south of the border and
elsewhere and so as far as the SNP are
concerned what happened after breaks it
and the results of that election are a
clear indication that the Scottish
people want to have another say when it
comes to Scottish independence we must
have the right to consider the
alternative of independence the question
of independence must be decided by the
people and not by politicians Scotland
made very clear last week that it does
not want a Tory government led by Boris
Johnson taking his out of Europe and
down a path that we haven't chosen but
that is the future we face if we don't
have the opportunity to consider the
alternative of independence now five
years ago there was a Scottish
independence referendum the Scottish
people voted by 55 percent to 45 percent
to remain in a union with the rest of
the United Kingdom and so the UK
government of Boris Johnson say that
that's it it's a once-in-a-lifetime
generation vote you don't get another
say but far as Scotland are concerned
breaks it changed everything the
Scottish people voted overwhelmingly by
around 2/3 of the population to remain
in the EU and with the UK looking to
leave the European Union by the end
next January moods are strengthening
north of the border
you